I
so welcome to the lightning talks is the
last session of pi data just first of
all we'd like to thank our sponsors once
again especially we like to thank
continuum the new amiss our diamond
sponsor and and continuum is responsible
for making a lot of what went on this
weekend happen so let's then continue
the I just want to thank the committee
the Local Organising Committee can you
stand up if you are on the committee dog
meat Valentin Philip sweater please
stand stand stand yeah you might be they
might not be in here okay just want to
thank james powell also helped on there
doing some review work and the other
people that helped on the review
committee are not here so we just want
to want to give them a big hand they put
in a lot hour
we have about five or six lightning
talks scheduled so do you want to want
to go first okay so first we have
valerio module i hope i pronounced that
correctly talking about building a PI
data community in Italy okay can you
hear me yes okay that's just uh that's
okay well sorry okay this is the title
of my talk I prepared this talk this
morning because inspired by the great
keynote by Travis on building a payday 2
community in Italy actually in Italy we
are a vibrant community of Python estes
and the organizer of the Python
community in Italy from 2007 to 2010
organized for different edition of the
Python Italian conference from Pike on
12 pikin for and we reached up to 400
attendees to distort to these to these
conferences from 2011 and 2013 as you
may already know and Italy there have
been Europe Python so your pattern has
been hostile italy in florence in
particular and this year we had pikin 5
in in May so the 5th edition of the
italian python conference we the
conference always has been held in
florence in yulee and these are the guys
or part of them then you that organize
these fantastic conference they made my
opinion a great
organization a great work this year also
immediately we had the jungle village it
has been the first time for a django
community to in italy to attend a unique
conference explicitly dedicated to the
django web framework so now it's for us
the time to move ahead and then we we we
started thinking about okay but what
about making a conference that may join
different communities in order to build
a broader conference a big conference
with different flavors inside it so
after after saying that we say okay
maybe a great idea to do this kind of
conference and then so we trying to
organize the next word the next edition
of the Python Italian conference which
is the pike on six that should cost of
course a Python track and it Django
track but now we won't like to let you
know that we will be really happy to
host and PI data tracking service this
conference the conference should be held
tentatively in on April the next year
and will be held for sure in Florence
and if you join Oh Florence is the city
of assassin creed so may a reason and
then another reason to come of course
and it will be great for us if we may
add to this list of European cities of
PI data also PI data Florence for the
next year so thank you very much or you
can detention stay tuned on pi day today
I team actually we try to register this
domain but as Giovanni already tweeted
few minutes ago we had some issues with
the registrants so please check this
page out for tomorrow or but anyway I
will create about this in the next days
so thank you very much
thank you very much so next up we have
adrian gaiden will have lightning talk
about video analytics and computer
vision in Python I need to help with Max
I never actually attended a lightning
talk so be kind to me it's my first
Python conference ever I'm research
scientists at Xerox Research Center
Europe in Grenoble so while this starts
up I can tell bit more about so what I
do so I I do video analytics so who here
maybe while it's getting up to here
knows about analytics knows the
definition of analytics nobody ever went
to Wikipedia and typed analytics in
Wikipedia okay so i will show you the
definition and that way you will be able
to do use that buzzword in this
industrial context because in industries
it's a it's as hot a buzzword as as Big
Data so max are very plug and play hey
cool we're getting we're getting there
okay sorry about that right so these are
just some pictures of where I work out
it's a Grenoble a workout it's a it's
really nice city okay video analytics so
analytics is the discovery and
communication of meaningful patterns in
data for videos it means discovering
means data analysis like classification
so you can use ticket learn for those
kind of things communication means that
a visualization something we discuss at
length here meaningful patterns in video
data means persons objects behaviors
events since those kind of things so why
video i guess i can go quick about that
but there's hundreds of billions of
online videos 100 of hours per minute
uploaded to youtube we're talking about
zettabytes of traffic
two million CCTVs in the UK one for
every 30 people lots of videos problem
is it's a digital black box so it's just
a bunch of pixels and there's lots of
research going on how to unbox many
potential applications and
transportation healthcare data
management and many many others and
probably this is the most interesting to
you I use Python and my colleagues at
Xerox use Python a lot for a computer
vision machine learning research insist
on research we don't make products we
make papers and we use it for clean
object-oriented abstractions with
scientific meaning like a detector and
tracker and and we use new pilots I
really really really love vectorization
and tensor tricks one of my goal in life
is to be able to use ein some of Mumbai
siphon we use a lot c c++ if c FF I
ffmpeg opencv i buy thin parallel paths
and notebooks recently Conda for
dependency hell management because a lot
of these things are not Python and in a
lot of code which is not open source for
now and I just wanted to show a couple
of videos highlighting recent results I
obtained using Python and maybe point to
use to some open open work that exerts
is doing on open that xerox com so let
me show you maybe I need to find out how
it's sorted just right so it's not
sorted alphabetically apparently mm-hmm
okay so what I'll show you is the end
result of what we can do hopefully it
works so this is typically the output of
the algorithm we want to to have for
action recognition so for actions action
recognition videos means trying to tell
what people are doing inside videos and
as I said it's a black box so what we're
trying to do is unbox it and unboxing it
means in this case adding nice colors
which corresponds to actually motion
parts that we can understand and we can
feed that to machine learning algorithms
to recognize what our actions so I'm
sorry this is very rough
there were other videos I wanted to show
you but I think I'm running out of time
and so feel free to come and I will show
you lots of cooler videos i think i have
20 or something so i hope it was ok for
lightning time ok thank you very much
the next speaker of fitting sunshine ok
then after that is a cover not about
pike astra nate is that correct or pike
Rastra Nate how do i pronounce it
correctly ok so hello everybody my name
is Felix I do Python for finance and for
those who have seen me on monday at the
european i'm giving a lightning talk i'm
sorry it's going to be exactly the same
the good news is it's going to be over
in just five minutes so i hope it's not
too bad i'm going to talk about two
packages they're called XL wings and XL
python as you probably figured they're
dealing with programming excel from
python and interacting with with excel
from python and excellence is my own
pack chi my own package excel python is
packaged by a guy called Eric grain oats
and the good thing about those two
packages is that they cover together
pretty much everything you ever wanted
to do with excel so they're pretty
complimentary and that's why we are
actually talking together and we want to
integrate them into one package at some
point when they are mature enough so I'm
going to start presenting Excel wings
and actually the next version i'm
expecting expecting it to be out next
week because it's going to add support
for excel on mac so the first package
actually in the python stack that
supports excel natively on mac so it's
easy to get started you just you know
create a workbook object from Excel
wings just import x-wings by the way the
homepage is excellent org there is also
a link on the to the other project XL
python and then it allows you to
I know oh yeah it allows you to interact
with Excel pretty much the way you use
to natively from excel vba you can also
read the values back using index
notation you can deal with a times you
can you know target various cells at the
same at the same at the same time you
can also carry over whole tables as
nested lists over here it takes care of
the non type strands transfers them into
empty cells and you can also use the
property table to read back a whole
contiguous cell array again so very
easily to you know juggle back and forth
data prom and to excel then it interacts
also very nicely with matrices from from
the numpy vampire race it sends them
over and if you want to read back in
directly non-pay arrays you can also
just specify the as array key word here
and it takes again the cells from over
here translating empty cells into na
ends then pana frames pandas dataframe
is actually pretty much the same you can
just read in the data you split off i'm
going actually from here from a from a
six you can split off the headers here
into the columns and the rest is the
data and then it's going to get you very
easily back your data frame and the same
story again if you want to put it over
into excel just assign it to an upper
left corner and you also have the
possibility to control index and headers
individually finally here you can also
have a one-liner for creating Excel
charts and set the range and tour type
so that's what's currently or what will
be available in the mac version from
next week now i'm on windows we have a
lot more features here we have also a
possibility to call these macros or
these scripts that you can write using
Excel wings you can call them from
within Excel so it really behaves like a
macro there is a native way currently in
Excel wings but if you
connected together with the other
package of Excel Python it's extremely
fast so it's very very much more
efficient then Excel Python gives you on
top and from now on I'm really just
showing you the functionality from Excel
Python it gives you a way to access
existing Python code without having to
change the Python code so no decorators
no nothing and the good thing you can
use this for example for functionality
that's not available in Excel so if you
want to build an inverse then you have
to M inverse function in Excel but if
you have a singular matrix then that's
not going to help you so it would be
good to have an p inverse function the
one from matt from from numpy so there's
a way to expose that in Excel using
Excel Excel Excel Python you built a
little wrapper and it looks a bit weird
and adds a lot of code but there's
actually a developer adding that can do
the code for you and the last thing i
want to show is there is a possibility
to also expose user-defined functions
from Python so I did quickly a portfolio
covariance matrix it's in native Excel
it's you know two matrix multiplications
1 transpose and if you apply this here
using a large enough matrix so 400 by
400 then this this on top is the result
so if i change the input it takes a very
long time in Excel to calculate that
just because the matrices are fairly big
if i do the same here using excel python
and not only the formula is simpler but
it's also very quick in kind in
calculating it that's about it thanks
thank you very much hi I'm going also to
present some lightning talk that was
with presented in in pike and sweet in
Europe Python and this is basically a
stripped-down version of a talk i did on
pike on sweden this year it's not super
data-driven but it has some data part in
it I hope you will enjoy it and there
you go so oops a bit too much of zone so
basically this is a tool that you would
use on your codebase to analyze and make
sense of all these to those and fix
missive have you can use it to extract
some metadata like who committed it when
it was committed and then with the
metadata you can play around so this
tall would be structured talking first
on the tool then some use cases on where
you can you can use it and if you want a
deeper version you can go to the github
link here where I have more
documentation and also the longer
version of the presentation in Python
Sweden but because we are in a lightning
talk and I don't know ever we have time
for everything let's just start with the
conclusions why do you wanna use it
first of all it's convenient you don't
have to change the way your programming
in any way and you can use it out of the
walk and in any language I know that
here we all use Python but sometimes
python is a good language and you are
dealing with some worse things you can
use it and secondly the only dependency
glass is Python 2 and Python 3 no weird
libraries it's very modular so right now
the modules it has are very basic but
for example if you like to build some
machine learning solution to compare the
number of to those and fix me if they
correlate with a number of Wiggly bugs
you discover this could be a good
approach and it's fast it's not super
fast or some machine learning tools we
have seen here but it's fast enough for
a real use case for example I used it on
Jango because it's a popular popular
library we all know and it's relatively
big 250k lines of Python because I'm
only looking at Python files
and I found more than 60 fixed knees and
to those 20 of them more than five years
old so even if it's a very supportive
and reputable library we see that this
is a problem and it needs to be
addressed probably our own code bases
also have similar problems but here you
can see I'm going to run it it just
three seconds it was not kidding and
here you get the results this is the
plane Council Bay console output version
it also has a HTML output person in its
modular if you want to want right one
for latex you can do it and basically
here immigrating the different types of
tokens and then the authors and then
here there are several columns that I
configured here which ones I wanted to
see and also I can configure which kind
of aggregation it's quite flexible so
having know their conclusions I'm going
to talk about the pipeline which is the
main the main skeleton of this program
basically there are eight different
parts I classified them like this and
given it to them and also you can do
more than one step at once for example
in the other files you would decide
which files one as easy as typing your
repo and the file extension inspect
files in our case with you some regular
expression to get all the fixed miss and
to those we could extract more metadata
apart from the date for example the
weekday maybe the important and then we
can also filter our results for example
if one developers out on vacation maybe
we don't want to bug him about some to
do that that's going there then this is
a bit more analysis so we can trigger
actions we can for example make our
continuous integration server break if
we have some rule that with an one there
we can aggregate the data to make it
easier to understand generate automatic
report and notifications this is just an
implementation detail / search results
because almost everything is lazily
evaluated you have to process the
results in the end or you would get
nothing so how do you configure design
and use it it's very easy you just need
a dictionary in the
configuration file and the first the key
would be the priority the order in which
will be executed and there are some of
the different functions or modules that
are available and then with a different
dictionary you just feed which
parameters you want to fit into them
here there are just a few they are much
more configurable but usually the falls
are enough so you don't have to include
them now we are done with the tool I
will explain just one use case because I
think I'm running out of time and let's
imagine we want to take control of code
base that's creeping with pics knees
what would be the first first we will
charge for fitness I think everybody
agrees on that and then for example we
want to filter those that are very old
and those that are more or less a couple
of weeks why not just take off fix miss
for example if your code is breaking a
production it may be reasonable to do
some ugly hack to make it work again in
production but we don't want all our
code after this to be reliable some bad
code so maybe after 15 days it's a good
indicator that this should not be here
we should fix it and we will email a
report to the committee and maybe to the
repository poner as well so we just need
to add two more lines of code to the cop
we previously saw Disick's cute and send
email modules this is clued module
basically you can just use any token you
one you write your own lambda function
and evaluate it and you can filter out
the results and this is the amount of
code it will take I think I'm run out of
time here you have some more examples
you can see them and yeah so to conclude
to do the it doesn't necessarily mean
that will be done it just means that
it's not done so made to the really mean
what we want and get rid of them thanks
okay thank you very much next up
Benjamin Wilson what's the title of your
talk by all means
oh we go but once you that yeah hello my
name is Benjamin who is heard of the
archive repository for scientific
articles a few oh that's good that's
what I was hoping because what I really
wanted to do is just show you something
useful we built for a demo I've been get
you to use it and maybe you'll find it
useful and you can use it every now and
then so for those that don't know the
archive is a repository for scientific
articles so well subfields particularly
at mathematics computer science physics
there's about 1,000,000 articles on
there they're all very recent but it has
become increasingly important it's
really changed the way we too we publish
scientific articles so I'm a
mathematician or at least I was I used
to use it a lot I still do to some
extent it's fantastic resource it's
great if you know which paper you want
to find but if you just want to explore
it's no good at all it really doesn't
even try to give you that functionality
I now work with together with another
mathematician Steve you might have met
at a company called lateral I oh and we
try and extract meaning from text and we
had to build a little demo just to show
we won't complete monkeys so we built
one and we use the archive data and
we're going to keep it up today and we
just put it out there because we thought
it's actually really useful so this is
what it looks like what it looks like is
also a work in progress but just to give
you an idea of what it does so I
recently did some work on word to that
so we find a paper by Michelob here up
the top
the information you got from the archive
but down the bottom you've got a related
article so these are articles that our
system believes are semantically related
now i don't think the recommendations I
think they're very good or they're at
least good we can certainly make them a
lot better but I think it's already at a
stage where it's really useful so if you
like it feel free to use it it's all I
wanted to say so the address is a
archived lateral I oh thanks yeah that
looks really useful thank you very much
so next up is I like Savio who is going
to be talking about py ss14 or is that
perhaps pronounced differently
this what it's been see I really wonder
why it's always such an issue to get
your laptop connected to your Beamer not
you know these things might have been
worked out by now you just sort of walk
up there connect it and go but ah there
we go well I I just prepared this in
five minutes we are from San Sebastian
in the north of Spain the rainy part we
are from the computational intelligence
group in the University of the Basque
Country we we have been working a lot
with a computer computer vision medical
image processing hyperspectral imaging a
matlab but lately we have been working
on python we are trying to build a small
Python community in the faculty and in
the in the area and we have we plan to
to do a meetup and Sebastian so we have
we have a very nice venue we have
experienced create doing conferences
organizing conferences we have a very
nice building in the university to do
that it's in front of the the beach so
one
we are also going to be going to a side
the house and well we might have
something for the vegetarians as well
yeah we just created a twitter account
for this we we we are still deciding on
the on the dates yeah so please it's
going to be inset september-october
depends on when the movie this cinema
festival ends so everyone is welcome and
thank
so I need to ask you is that is the name
intentional is that something is there
is there a hidden joke there yeah well
we voted for the name we don't have
we're not it's not definitely but I mean
it's a good candidate all right well
thank you very much so now we come to
our last at least the last lightning
talk on the schedule so if you do want
to give a lightning talk after this just
whip one out and feel free to just come
up here and wait so the next talk is by
sylveon Bella Mia i hope i pronounced
that correctly okay silver okay Silvana
Bella Mia and it's going to be about
provisioning the syfy stack with
saltstack sits all stack yeah but it's a
bit of a pretentious title I just made
it up now because that was not this is
it totally improvised I'm totally new to
data science side by an empire I'm just
software developer working with python
django for it more in two years now so i
was a bit not suspicious or not
skeptical but curious to see how
difficult it is to install syfy or an m
pi so i decided not to use Conda or an
account or mini Conda right away I
decided to try to install myself like
using paper or something so what I ended
up doing just friday saturday and today
over a conference in my free time
between the very tight schedule is to
provision a small VirtualBox I quit
vagrant and using saltstack so I thought
I'd I'll share that because if you
happen to be curious and see or want to
control more environment or something to
just or play around I thought it could
be useful to you so oh yeah today was
this talk about Conda by Iran I
from continually analytics and he was
mentioning that for instance installing
h p8 h 5 pi was a bit difficult you know
so i decided to try to do it this way
with saltstack and virtualbox so it
works maybe I show you instead in the
terminal so I won't do it because it
takes a lot of time the first time you
build it but once you ssh to the
VirtualBox let's see if I run start the
ipython notebook specified the you can
grab before doing that you do what you
would do you you'll run I have conflict
to know what's the IP of the virtual
machine and then after that you'll run
without the browser and then you go to
the host machine and let's say this is a
notebook not and just to check ok is
really is everything really install
seems that yes so that's about it I mean
there's no okay now if you want to know
maybe if you're curious to know what's
behind that there's a vagrant file
there's a that's ass all state and this
is worse stuff is happening so I mean I
don't know if you if you don't know
about sauce szostak it's new to me too I
find it very useful very clear so you
just specify what the state that you
would like a machine to be in you know
which package should be there which
packages should be there and and then
the virtual environment is being
provisioned I saw yesterday that some
guy developed assault state Madhu for
Conda so that means instead of using
virtual environment there you could use
Conda to provision also your so if I
think many of you it seems you're like
or really like to use condo and anaconda
but let's see you want it to do that
just locally spin up a virtual machine
to test some stuff and you and because
the thing that is really useful with
that you can easily destroy and recreate
the machine that the problem with that
it will take time maybe especially with
a side pipe may take like 15 20 minutes
but still you can have many many many
virtual machines that you can experiment
with if you want to and you can move
that easily towards a amazon also if you
wanted to provision like an Amazon
servers you know there's a vague vagrant
or their soundcloud also that you could
use so that I mean it's not plan you
know I just decided I wanted to share
what I did a bit over weekend besides
attending the talks so I don't know in
case it would be useful some people so
that's about it if you have questions
you can ask me okay thank you right so I
guess there's no one else wanting to
give another lightning talk alrighty so
that's it for the conference thanks
again to all our sponsors continuum add
square me notes immobilien scout clicks
blue yonder back data so i hope i hope i
have all of you Emma nodes I think I
mentioned them and a special thanks to
all of you attendees this is sort of
always the most important part of a
conference is actually the people that
attend otherwise there would just be
sort of speakers on stage speaking to an
empty room so give yourselves a big hand
thanks again to all of you for attending
I hope you had a great time
you
you